i asked you guys who would you want to
have as your phone up front
chris you were kind enough to say me uh
but you'll see in a second i'm a [ __ ]
compared to this man
honestly smartest guy i know is my
brother
and the smartest guy i've ever worked
with is this guy with all due respect to
everyone else i've worked with
you take a princess there really is a
one of a kind he's a diamond in the
rough he is my buddy who i love
uh his name is jeremy shep how are you
jeremy you're there
i'm very nervous right now don't like
there's no money on the line here
there's a lot on the line after that
it's just pride preamble it's probably
there's a lot of preamble
and and i'm i didn't know this was going
to be a quiz
i didn't know this was going to be a
quiz no i think he'll be fine
jeremy have you ever been asked to be a
phone a friend for anybody
uh at all in any should never it's never
been
never you would be mine no absolutely
mine i appreciate that
thank you no i'm jealous i mean you know
i mean what mina got to do that's like
that's like a dream that's what it makes
a dream come true and to nail it
that's why i want you because you want
the pressure
jeremy you want the moment you want the
challenge
you what did would you have gotten the
question that she nailed correctly
do you know it did you know what she got
my
i remember it was the the electricity
white house and benjamin harrison was
the correct answer right right yes
would you gotten that yeah my my look
i i could say whatever i want right um
when i
heard it my instinct was harrison
but would i stuck with it through all
the pressure of five minutes of
this and that and then they they like
gave you like 50
right no they go down did they like no
they didn't do that
no you'd have been the phone a friend
you'd give me you had 30 seconds to give
me an answer you would have told me
harrison right come on now
right you would have as far as we know i
would
okay now i mentioned before that you're
you're experts uh you're expert at so
many things uh vice presidents of the
united states you know them correct you
know them very very well
i'm pretty i'm pretty good okay uh the
succession of british royalty
you're very very good at that i've seen
this in person right since the battle of
hastings
okay and when and when the dollar bills
had on the note
to use the phrase uh uh letters
associated with the federal reserve
at which they were printed you used to
have those alphabetically arranged in
your wallet correct
right i did okay when they had those
notations okay and to this day you
probably do remember which letters are
associated with it with which federal
reserve correct jeremy
i think so okay very good i haven't been
asked
president to serve under two different
presidents
john c calhoun
maybe that's correct but i have george
clinton
there are two okay there you go and
calhoun
clinton served under jefferson and
madison
calhoun served under adams and jackson
okay
very good and uh you were just asking
for one i didn't want to correct you not
in the you you yeah
and uh okay how about this one let's
let's chris i'm telling
you this is my phone i get it okay this
is my phone of frank
um the uh not only that george clinton
hold on george clinton was vice
president under both
jefferson and madison and when madison
ran for re-election
in 1816
he defeated clinton's i believe
nephew de wick clinton it was kind of a
uh you know inter-family kind of thing
going there biking the football now
which is wonderful
okay so now i've got one for you here uh
the the tenth vice
the tenth vice president of the united
states was who and his first name uh
is the letter in his letter is the first
name for which federal reserve
jay is hold on hold on hold on
it's i said it was a long time esses
atlanta mm-hmm
uh h is saint louis rise minneapolis
j is kansas city that's correct wow
correct that is correct
and uh k kansas city starts with the
letter k which is the federal reserve
for which other city dallas that's
correct oh my god
come on
[Laughter]
this is mine now that now wait
james k pope's vice president he was
like of course in 1844
his vice president was george m dallas
and it was around this time when dallas
actually was established
but the last time i checked it's still
uncertain and i lived in dallas for a
couple of years as you remember rich
whether dallas is named for george m
dallas or someone else it's kind of
unclear it's one of
the great questions i think of american
uh name uh
geographical name origins okay
do you understand why i'm doing this
chris you understand why we're doing uh
jeremy uh uh honestly i like shaking i'm
so nervous actually
i'm nervous you haven't you haven't
gotten this is anything incorrect
do you want to do the chris you have a
royals question for him you want to call
up the
suggestion of british royalty because
honestly
you're the guy jeremy you're taxes but
i'm getting older no you're not
you're you're absolutely completely
nailing this sort of thing
i got one rich okay what do you got over
there
who was the first vice president jeremy
to become
president without being elected
without being elected so would have been
the first one when the president died in
office
that would be the man we've already
mentioned
john tyler survey says yes
that's correct jeremy shap everybody
john tyler both
the 10th president and the 10th vice
president
and of course as i'm sure you're aware
rich just within the last few weeks
um one of his grandsons died
that's true and he still has a living
grandson
this is a man who was president
almost 200 years ago and he has a living
grandson
whoa it's amazing there was a story
about tyler's grandson the living
uh the remaining surviving grandson i
think in the journal yesterday
and watched this two days ago watch this
turn watch this turn
jeremy what'd you think of mike tyson
and roy jones what'd you think of that
one
i refused to watch
[Laughter]
i refused to watch you know i usually
i'm okay with being hypocritical
but i had said i i had done a number of
commentaries like this is ridiculous you
cannot encourage
geriatric feudalism and people say yeah
but you're going to watch
i thought maybe i would fold but i just
fell asleep
it was entertaining i would not have
watched though okay i i can't do it i
can't do it right
i i i said in the comments all right so
what they couldn't get dempsey and tony
i mean this is ridiculous it really was
quite something you missed out you
missed snoop with the call
that's fine that's i'll get a chance to
watch it
all right so uh you know what that's it
do you know the significance give me
something else give me something with a
hey you know i spent a lot of time over
the years memorizing useless things and
literally appearing on the rich eisen
shows the only time i
ever get to use it because now
everybody's got a computer in their
pocket
i know that so i guess i don't where
would i even find the the succession of
british royalty do you have it up there
chris
in front of me i'm looking up i'm
looking up obscure british royalty
trivia
apparently they're not allowed to play
monopoly
that i did not know i didn't wha why why
because they have a monopoly on
everything else
like is that what it is i don't know the
queen has someone break in her shoes for
her
i didn't know that either i did not know
all right so
it's strictly it's strictly
chronological the succession
liam the first up through elizabeth ii
in
order that's what i know okay knowledge
is
broad but not deep well how did they get
the name windsor
jeremy why do they go by windsor now
well they chose windsor because they
were sax cobra gotham that became
inconvenient during the great war when
they were fighting against germany and
you know after george the first became
king
upon the death of queen anne in i
believe 1714
um you know they were always considered
kind of interlopers from
germany and 200 years later the great
war they didn't want to be called
saxophone gossip they'd been
um hannover of course under the georgies
of william the fourth and then when
victoria was queen
uh you know she married um albert who
was also german
and and so they didn't want to be sax
cobra gossa anymore it sounded too
dramatic so they adopted the name of the
castle razor
did they get that right chris
checks out wow god bless you jeremy shap
i love that diamond in between your
temples
uh if i ever if i ever
oh my god no it's just you oh hold on a
second i just got emailed the line of
succession
i'm going to have you do it and then we
will okay actually is this the is this
the
current is this the current top 10 is
that what it is because you do you know
the current one
i can't get i mean i could figure that
out i'm talking about
you know who has been the monarch since
1066 and a little bit before because
edward the confessor was monarch for
like 30 years before that then harold
hard drive then
the first but if you're talking about
who are the 10 people in line now
yes i mean i can figure that out
obviously it's first
charles and obviously it's second
william that it's his three kids
then it's um uh harry
and and then it was i don't know anymore
harry has a kid
so harry's kid only has one child
right so it would be harry's kid and
then you would go back to
oh i think you're right i think you're
right on all this i get a little
confused because they changed it it used
to be the male
you know the male always superseded the
female but they changed that in recent
years but i don't know if that's
retroactive so honestly i don't know if
anne is now
ahead of andrew and edward by the way
this is
this is the worst lineup card ever i
mean i think i i i think in
enrico palazzo would throw out this
lineup all right so
uh last one chris you've got another one
more a pentathlon
uh pentathlon question which pin tab i
love the modern pentathlon
obviously which pentathlete has done
we're talking about the modern
pentathlon or we talk about the regular
pentax
the modern pentathlon which olympic
athlete uh pentathlete has the most
olympic medals
in the event
no idea i'm going to guess
that it's someone from
hungary but i don't know i don't know
pavel
lednev of the ussr between 68 and 80.
he won seven all right jeremy sadly uh
sadly you're no longer my phone a friend
uh it's it's over damn it you got
everything up to this one actually here
here you go let's we can't end on that
i know i know i feel bad now who are or
who are both
who are both vice presidents for ulysses
s grant before you go out the door
uh his first vice president was skyler
colfad that's correct and his second
vice president was henry wilson
thank you jeremy that's call to walk off
you may drop your phone
thank you right back at you thank you
jeremy chef love you too let's see
rich i'm going to need his number just
in case i get on me yeah i'm telling you
now i feel bad for giving him that's my
phone i want him to be my phone a friend
now
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here